another day another Call of Duty leaked
these have to be on purpose at this
point right anyway I'm Tony and this is
your special edition game spot news
update if you plan on picking up Call of
Duty World War two you'll have a new
option in the Pro Edition that probably
doesn't surprise you but we did get a
glimpse of what the package contains via
Twitter the image shows the game itself
a steelbook case and the game's season
pass this is the first confirmation of
said season pass but I'm betting you're
not too surprised by that either in any
case you can tune into the official Call
of Duty livestream on Wednesday April
26th at 10 a.m. Pacific 1 p.m. Eastern
we'll be watching and commentating over
at GameSpot so be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to hear that breakdown
previous leaks revealed some screenshots
and a Friday November 3rd release date
for the game we should receive more
official word on that during the live
stream but for more on military shooters
right now you can check out the latest
episode of reboot
[Music]